hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the bottle flip challenge
we've got a bunch of water bottles and
we got a bunch of friends so what we're
gonna be doing is we're going to be
taking turns flipping this water bottle
on this thing it's gonna be an
elimination style round for the first
one originally we're just gonna do a
very basic flip and if you get it you're
out and you're safe if you don't get it
you have to keep flipping down the line
until you get to the last person and the
last person not able to get the flip
gets shot with arrows in the face
preferably not everywhere but the face
in the dick shots they're getting shot
with an arrow
so to recap that gonna go first
giant five way rock-paper-scissors yeah
two three you guys play off four four
and five alright so I'm pretty sure I'm
safe these guys aren't very good
[Music]
[Laughter]
so good this our first try
okay so I lost I get shot in the back in
the DA it's a hard target what are you
aiming for so we're gonna be a little
farther away we got a line in the sand
here giant five-way rock paper scissors
why don't we just go in reverse order of
who lost lost I'm all right you know
okay all right yes of you then Bob then
me then Tyler
whoa one eternity later ok [ __ ] it's so
close every time the REO technique
it's like granny style you know granny
shot my granny never did that
the granny never did this no my granny
yeah we suck so we decided that Tyler is
better than us in every way every way
every single way he's better than us
he's proven this by this one I happen
he's better than us in every way so he's
gonna shoot all of us with arrows if he
can be shot there's a fly go it came
back to me oh you don't get to shoot it
again you can't hit anything
[Applause]
I didn't our to your cat that was right
on my oh Jesus okay well Bob's going for
this I want chug chug chug chug chug
okay so now we're going to do with the
big bottle flip Bob is currently working
on the bottle alright so we got our big
ball ready I drink that whole thing it's
full now it's empty
anyway
[Laughter]
Oh oh nice oh I know all right now we're
gonna [ __ ] him up no I'm here because I
was this is how we do it
[Laughter]
he said chuck it over
I won your 20 bucks I want to win double
or nothing am I still going yes you're
going
I know I think you should have to go
again watching how do we know a liar man
how do we know we know says you don't
make it don't go over lie you were like
this is me you're gonna you go two times
in a row no no let him butter let's see
[Laughter]
cut out every single here yeah I didn't
[Music]
have to ask
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you everybody so much for watching
why that was the bottle flip challenge
but we've got more flipping action for
you that we did on our own then we're
gonna show you guys because we had a ton
of fun just like practicing and playing
around with flipping stuff in you know
[Music]
it wasn't that fun
that was cool okay so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
Bob wait Tyler whatever your name is
for joining us and we really appreciate
you all for watching hope you enjoyed it
anyway see you in the next one so that
was fun this is definitely not the third
time we've done this outro anyway so
thanks everybody so much for watching
thank you Bob Tyler Wayne Ethan for
being here all the links in the
description and let us know what you
thought if you want to see something
like this again in the future let us
know down in the comments below thanks
again for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]